the way that I think about brand from a
visual perspective is like imagine a
bouquet of flowers so you have all these
different flowers inside of it so when
you put all of them together the bouquet
has an identity right now if you take
out one flower and put it in a different
flower it does shift it a little bit now
if I break one of the flowers or make it
rotten it really shifts it which is why
if you get a DUI or girl as a really
good guy all of a sudden it completely
shifts the bouquet despite all the other
flowers that you've done and associated
with those flowers are bad now right
exactly you can't hand your girlfriend
just one flower that's rotten they she
be like why did you give me a rotten
bouquet even though the rest of ours are
totally fine